pas bien
le chat maintien
2les
et c'est un moment spécial c'est votre
première entrevue depuis que vous avez
inquiéter l'an passé avec vous en
ressentez vous avez écrit j'ai failli
mourir noyé par trois fois
ses parfums
je me rappelle je suis chez moi puis je
vais tomber juste à puis je fais tu veux
vraiment mener me chercher tout de suite
je me sens que j'ai encore d'autres
choses à faire avancer et pour chercher
tout de suite mais là je me suis
accroché à pain puis le chantre
l'hôpital d'urgence bien non puisque je
suis pour mais à chaque fois que
survient fait moquer
d'autres choses à faire
pour vos 76 ans vous recevez tout un
cadeau vous est nommée chevalière de la
légion d'honneur pour la fin parce que
ça c'est une fugue rom si gratifiant
j'adore le trophy j'adore le médaille
j'adore les prix je le prends avec des
fois je me suis un petit peu mal à
l'aise mais je les prends avec tout ce
que je peux comme quand ce type si james
où il m'était dit colin des affaires des
images une donnée des images ou du
conasur mais j'avais une impression de
vendre la valeur
c'est gratifiant pour moi c'est surtout
ça vient notre bas au fait que souci
c'est une fan cerisy que les maïs pol
bury même ou sur l'essentiel
c'est d'être aimé vous à lui tout un
succès en france au fait le désarroi 60
ans car plus de 60 ans de carrière
comment ça se passe en france pour mais
je sais pas des fois je me pose la
question si je me suis pour saboter moi
même
parce que je suis une personne qui a
pris beaucoup de poids un moment donné
je suis parti de sang de salive je suis
monté jusqu'à 306 à peu près en ce
moment je peux 194 juive et je pense que
c'est plutôt la substance qui a eu le
sait comment lever mois tous m'ont
enlevé moi pour ma bouffe comme un écho
à l'aise qu'un alcoolique drogué
c'était si a fallu que je fasse un
j'ai fait beaucoup de démarches
beaucoup de g j'ai fait cinq ans dans ce
monastère pour essayer de découvrir
c'est donc parce que je me pensais ne
plus en ces moments mieux j'ai vu je
t'ai pas de se donner plus à ceux que
moi est ce que vous vous souvenez de la
journée qu'on a passé tous les deux à
boucherville michel drucker vous a
surnommé la edith piaf du québec vous
souvenez de sens parce que je me
rappelle j'avais perdu beaucoup de poids
et comme j'avais perdu beaucoup de
montrer mes cuisses pêcheries des belles
cuisses mais je te donne aussi fa cup
mais lui c'est non non non non vous ne
faut pas parce qu'ils aient le
répertoire que vous chantez ça n'a rien
à voir avec ce que vous portez alors
vous êtes né il dit pierre vous étonner
des piats puis quand j'ai chanté et
dernièrement je suis à l'iae quelques
années on disait les hippies bienfaits
revenue cet entraînement
et donc sortir jambes je faire un détour
par l'actuel aller parce que la semaine
passée votre ami guy la frise étaient
toutes les bêtes a été visiblement ému
comment vous avez vécu ça parce que
trait aux touailles et pendant tout le
monde oublie très troublée j'étais
à chaque fois j'ai quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup pic avec qui j'ai comme les
murs
j'ai troublé j'en ai pour une fois
encore je suis heureux c'est pas facile
parce que c'est un vrai gentleman tout
le monde le dit wang et enfin saint
maurice richard sainct ginette reno
c'est comme se situe vraiment un grand
passionné la dernière fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés vous parliez d'une
autobiographie et à quoi ça va parler
d'eux qu'on vous avez voulu parler parce
que c'est ça sera pas comme une
biographie lorsqu'on lit pondi banal et
ça va être surtout comme de a à z
argent amour à vos corps
boissons sexe du certificat me dont
celles de personnes et était la sienne
jour qui évoque à cet état de fait le
cycle est ce que tu avais eu lieu à
sucre dont nous parlait puis le sa part
que je raconte tout le dieu vengeur du
punissable j'avais vu comment je m'en
suis fait un qui était mon père puis ma
mère à la fois après sept saisons le
sexe
le sexe tant que c'est comme de haut a à
z j'arrive
[Musique]
comment croire
non
et puis vous avez aussi un nouvel album
et une tournée aussi pour l'automne oui
manquerait pas de travail c'est parce
que chaque fois que je fais quelque
chose je le fais comme si c'était la
dernière fois j'ai pu comme sûr
maintenant moi je ville comme c'était la
dernière fois ce dernier atteint la
donner foi de 60 ssl oxbow chants appris
ça me fait du bien j'ai le feu sacré le
feu sacré
c'est tout
ginette reno merci pour votre générosité
vous avez été un vrai livre ouvert la
série
si je reste
sans toi